RYAN SANDS: Welcome to the talk.
Thanks for coming.
We're here to welcome and
talk to Bryan Lee O'Malley.
He is a Canadian.
And also he is a part--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Are there
any Canadians in the house?
RYAN SANDS: Oh my.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
That's out of here.
RYAN SANDS: I grew
up in Michigan.
It's very close.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Oh yeah.
That's-- you're
basically Canadian.
RYAN SANDS: I grew
up with DeGrassi.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
But I hate you.
RYAN SANDS: Brian's
also a cartoonist.
He's author of "Lost at Sea,"
and the wildly successful,
and popular, and awesome
"Scott Pilgrim" series,
which was made into a
movie by Edgar Wright.
And a game and
some other things.
It's being released right
now in color additions.
I think-- is five out yet?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Five
is coming out next week.
RYAN SANDS: Oh.
How exciting.
And he's here to
talk about "Seconds,"
his new graphic novel, which
just came out on Tuesday.
I read it on the
way home from work.
And it's fabulous.
But yeah, so thank you.
And can you please help me
introduce Bryan-- welcome him.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
I won't clap.
RYAN SANDS: I'm gonna get
progressively sweatier
throughout the night.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: You're
wearing a sweatshirt.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
That's what happens.
It's called that for a reason.
Anyway.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
So.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Hello.
RYAN SANDS: I have a
bunch of questions.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: OK.
RYAN SANDS: I wrote
some of them down.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
We knew each other
prior to this--
whatever this is.
RYAN SANDS: We're
Twitter friends.
You follow me.
I almost DM'd you.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: We've met.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: And
you do comics as well.
RYAN SANDS: Oh yeah.
So outside of work, I publish
comics in a small little press.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Publisher of some renown.
RYAN SANDS: You're
taking over the--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: I'm
just intro'ing you properly.
That's all.
RYAN SANDS: So I read
the book on Tuesday.
I grabbed it on the BART home.
I really loved it.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: They
sell it on the BART?
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
At the BART station.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Someone
just sold it to you at the BART?
RYAN SANDS: I bought it
with the clipper card.
It's my favorite
thing you've done.
Which is an interesting
and exciting thing to say,
because I love your
previous work so much.
But it made me-- I'm 32.
It made me feel like
I'm 32 in like a--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: It
was like a reality check.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
Like in a sad way, and
then like a happy way too.
I was like, wow.
And I think for me, like
when I think about being 30,
it is about like accepting
a lot of really dumb cliches
that people always
tell you that are true.
And you're like, oh goddamnit.
That's true.
So I think a lot of the book
was about-- when I read it
on Tuesday, it reminded
me of like-- it's
about accepting the fact
that you're the sum of all
the good and bad
choices you've made.
And so everything you have or
don't have, or lost or enjoy
is the sum of all
these weird choices.
So I wonder how much of the
book was actually a response
to the success of
"Scott Pilgrim?"
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: It's a
hard question to parcel out.
RYAN SANDS: I'm sorry.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
No, it's fine.
It's a good place
to start, I guess.
While I was working
on "Scott Pilgrim,"
I was annoyed that
it was-- I'm not sure
how I'm going to phrase this.
I got a really bad review in
the Comics Journal in 2006,
on the third "Scott
Pilgrim" book.
So I was like, why doesn't
the art comics establishment
like me?
And I wanted to do
something, I wanted
to do a book that's
more arty and literary,
and dark and serious.
So for years that's
what I was thinking
that I would do after
"Scott Pilgrim."
And then when I
finally got there,
"Scott Pilgrim" had
already become successful.
And I didn't care that I had
a bad review in a magazine.
So I was like, I'm gonna take
this darker subject matter
and just try to make it
really fun, entertaining,
and true to myself.
And not just entirely a
reaction to "Scott Pilgrim."
There's aspects to the story--
the story's about a girl who
works in a successful
restaurant, but she wants more.
And she's trying to start her
own more successful restaurant
on her own terms.
So that's obviously
a clear metaphor
for me wanting to move on
and start something new.
So there's that.
But from there, it just kind of
spins off into it's own thing.
RYAN SANDS: I thought
it was interesting too,
in the story, the second
restaurant that the protagonist
is thinking to
start, she's like,
I'm going to control the
name, and how it looks,
and it's going to be mine again.
I thought that must be-- a lot
of our friends are cartoonists,
and it's like the most solitary,
singular-- like writing.
Where you're just
alone with your ideas.
And so it must have
been interesting to work
on something that eventually
became a shared project.
There's a lot of people who
were working on "Scott Pilgrim."
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: It
was like an industry.
It was like 500 people had jobs
because of "Scott Pilgrim."
So that was weird.
It was weird to
relinquish that control.
In the early days of
the movie planning,
it was maybe four or five of us.
And that was fun.
It was a little
tight knit group.
But then it got way
out of hand, and I
felt like I was this figurehead.
Because I didn't really have
anything to do with the movie
aside from they would
ask me a question,
and I would answer it.
And that's about all I did.
But during the actual movie,
I was just standing there,
and everyone was like,
oh, it's the guy.
So it had all this adulation,
but it was kind of meaningless.
And I didn't really have--
it was completely out
of my control.
It was this whole crew.
I was not even a
part of it at all.
RYAN SANDS: And it's like
Katie, the main protagonist,
has that same experience,
but at a restaurant
where she's walking
around asking
people how their food is.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Right.
RYAN SANDS: But
she didn't make it.
Because she made the thing, and
now it's running without her.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Yeah, exactly.
Her ideas live on without her.
And everyone still loves
them, and they love her.
I mean some of the
stuff like that,
is almost subliminal for
me to put in the book.
But now that you mention it,
it sounds a lot like my life.
RYAN SANDS: I think when I
was thinking about the book,
after I finished it
and started rereading,
I realized that both of
the books-- both the "Scott
Pilgrim" series
and the new book--
are about consequences in a way.
And I don't think
I saw that when
I read "Scott Pilgrim" as a
teenager and as a college kid.
But it's about dealing with
the consequences of having
had relationships with people.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
You were not a teenager
when "Scott Pilgrim" came out.
RYAN SANDS: When the first one
came out, I was a teenager.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: No.
It came out 10 years ago.
RYAN SANDS: Was I forever 21?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: 22.
RYAN SANDS: Oh shit.
Was I?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: You
just said you were 32.
RYAN SANDS: Oh.
I didn't know you were going
to be doing mental math.
I was trying to sound--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
We're at Google.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
That's true.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: This
is how they do basic math.
RYAN SANDS: OK.
I was a young'un.
And then I've grown.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
You felt like a teen.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: So did I.
RYAN SANDS: I still think of
myself as a tween, deep down.
The new book is about
consequences too,
in terms of more career and
sort of generalized path stuff.
And then the really exciting
thing that isn't just quickly,
is this sort of
monkey's paw element.
Where like, what if you
could change things?
And the implications of that.
Can you talk a little bit
about how in the book,
you're using that impulse to
use fantastical elements to talk
about pretty real stuff?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Right.
I mean I think the fantastical
elements came first.
I was sort of
inspired by this story
that my mom used
to read to me when
I was a little kid, about a
boy who finds a second chance
ticket.
And he accidentally
let's his dog run away,
and then he just
fills out this ticket,
and says he wishes
he didn't do it.
And then it's undone.
That's the entire story.
RYAN SANDS: The dog
doesn't come back undead?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
The dog is just back.
Yeah, that's the end.
It's like, oh,
everything's fine.
His mom comes home
and everything's fine.
A simple story.
But it always stuck in my head.
I worked in this restaurant
and I started thinking about
the second chance ticket,
and restaurant, and then
this idea of this house
spirit thing, which
is kind of an old Russian
folklore sort of thing--
Eastern European-- that
there is like a spirit that
reigns over your house, but
it's almost a benevolent thing.
So all that stuff kind of
meshed together in my mind
when I was working
at this restaurant.
And I had a lot
of time to think,
because I was the food runner.
All I did was bring food
from the basement kitchen
to the diners, and not
really interact with anyone.
So I was just looking
over the sketch book
and having ideas for stuff.
And I just let this kind
of grow for six years
while I was finishing
"Scott Pilgrim."
RYAN SANDS: You've had
this idea, or the kernel
of the idea, for a long time?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
Literally the first
"Scott Pilgrim" came out
and I made no money, and I
got a job in a restaurant.
And that's where I had
the idea for "Seconds."
So it's been there
since the beginning.
RYAN SANDS: Dishwashing
cartoonist is like
a well-known, revered--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Classic archetype.
RYAN SANDS: Michael
DeForge was a dishwasher.
I've heard of many other--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
He might have
worked in the same
restaurant as me.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah, you guys--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: In Toronto.
Yeah.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
I thought the setting
was really interesting.
It takes place in a
restaurant, as we mentioned.
And it seems like chefs in
restaurants are very in vogue
in terms of-- not in vogue,
but fascinating to people.
Like there's a special magic.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: It seems
like a celebrity culture
right now.
They're like a rock star.
RYAN SANDS: Feels like
it's like that and stand up
are these two things
that-- there's podcasts,
and people really want to know
the unique qualities of it.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Cartoonists.
RYAN SANDS: And cartoonists.
Yeah.
We don't have a WTF
podcast for us yet.
But I was interested about--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: First.
You starting it.
RYAN SANDS: But what about
a restaurant, I guess,
is unique or magical.
Like a restaurant has a
house spirit, but maybe
not like this office, perhaps?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Right.
Yeah.
The restaurant where I worked
was a really old building.
I've always liked old buildings.
They've always been
fascinating to me.
But then the restaurant-- it's
like a working restaurant is
its own closed community.
And there's always
interesting characters
that work in a restaurant.
It's very ethnically
diverse generally.
And it just seemed like a
natural place to tell a story,
if I'm going to stick to
"write what you know."
The only other thing I know
other than drawing comics
is, I worked at a
restaurant for six months.
That's all my life
experience to date.
And it just made sense to me.
I like food, and I
like chefs, and I
like writing about
boisterous, outgoing people.
I'm not like that at all.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah,
there's a lot of yelling,
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
It fascinates me.
Yeah.
And people are just kind
of really over the top.
And so I wanted to write
a character like that.
RYAN SANDS: Do have
chef friends who--
there's actually a really good--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Work at Google?
I do actually have a chef
friend who works at Google.
RYAN SANDS: There's a
really good recipe in there.
And I was like,
that sounds real.
It actually sounds
really delicious.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: It is.
I do have chef friends.
The friend who got me
the job at the restaurant
originally owns his own
restaurant in Toronto now,
called Me & Mine.
So if anyone ever goes to
Toronto, check out Me & Mine.
It's really good.
And another friend in LA
is a dabbler, I guess.
And he came over and
cooked this recipe,
so I could take detailed
reference photos.
And he made it up.
It's a crazy recipe with rabbit
with a green tea reduction.
I never would have
thought of it.
RYAN SANDS: Mushrooms in it.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
Mushrooms-- that was
important for the story.
And he just invented
this recipe.
He came over and
did it one night.
And we all ate it.
And it was delicious.
And I put it in the book.
RYAN SANDS: There's
also a hamburger
that looks really good.
There's some really tasty foods.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
The hamburger is my-- I had an
art assistant on this book--
Jason Fisher, who's well-known
for drawing hamburgers.
That's his thing.
So I gave him one big
juicy burger to draw.
RYAN SANDS: My wife
has a patch of his.
It's a huge hamburger.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
he makes these patches
that he puts on jean jackets.
Some of them are this big.
You put it on the back
of your denim jacket.
A giant burger.
RYAN SANDS: You're at
that level now where
you can be like, I need the best
hamburger drawer in the world.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Get
me the best burger drawer.
Only the best.
RYAN SANDS: You
went to Hollywood,
and now you're a tyrant.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Comics tyrant.
RYAN SANDS: The other
thing I want to talk about
was the fairytale
structure of it.
And the part that
felt that way was,
there's this disconnection
between the narrator
and the way that the
actual main character
argues with the narrator
version of herself.
So I was curious to
see-- a lot of people
made a lot of fuss about
the manga connections
in "Scott Pilgrim."
So I was curious, some of which
I think were real influences,
and some were just sort of like,
oh that's cute-- must be manga.
For the new book, you mentioned
the child's book that you read.
What were some of the
other comics influences?
Because it feels like way
different tonally, and also
the look of it is different.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
I mean I was more
inspired by European
comics this time.
Like French stuff.
Franco-Belgian influence.
Like Donjon was a huge--
RYAN SANDS: Oh, dungeon.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Dungeon in English.
Donjon.
It was a huge thing for me.
That was even before
"Scott Pilgrim,"
it was maybe 2002, 2003.
I was just obsessively
collecting these books
that no one's probably
ever heard of.
But their--
RYAN SANDS: It's one of my
favorite comics of all time.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Of course it is.
But they're these French albums.
And this famous dude named--
who's the guy who started it?
Trondheim started it?
RYAN SANDS: Nsfar.
Yeah.
Trondheim Nsfar.
They started this
series where-- they
started volume
one of the series,
and then they did volume--
I think, 99 and negative 99.
So that it was the origins
of all the characters,
and then the far
apocalyptic future
of all the same characters.
And they were like, we're
going to meet in the middle.
We're going to do 100
books on either side.
I think they did five.
But they're all amazing.
Its such a mind
boggling concept.
And the art was so beautiful.
It was really inspiring as
a starting-out cartoonist.
RYAN SANDS: It's also--
they're small looks too.
Each one's 40 pages.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Only 40 pages.
But they're really dense.
RYAN SANDS: It's the far future.
You're like, oh
no, he hates him.
And he's like--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
He has no arms.
It's really crazy.
It was a huge influence on
"Adventure Time," I know that.
Pen loved that stuff.
RYAN SANDS: I guess I was
thinking a lot of your stories
are very epic.
This story is a very
small story and--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Small epic.
It's an internal epic.
RYAN SANDS: In terms of like,
it doesn't cover that much time.
It's like one character's life.
But it's a huge project.
I was wondering, did
you have an impulse
to do shorter stuff
before you started,
or did you always
see it as a big book?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
I always saw it as exactly
this size and shape.
RYAN SANDS: Oh perfect.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
I had to fill out
those pages with something.
RYAN SANDS: With
the little image
of you tweeting on the toilet.
If you guys haven't
seen it, you'll
see Bryan and other
friends in the background.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Yeah, I mean, this
is the trend size
of the Tezuka books
from Vertical, which are my
favorite presentation of comics
right now.
And I just wanted it
to feel like a novel.
So that was one of
the initial goals,
was just the actual physical
dimensions of the book.
And I wanted a story that would
fit in that package basically.
And I wanted to tell
a story about a boss,
about someone who's
actually done some stuff,
but is still fucked up.
So I had to wait
until I was old enough
to tell a story like that.
RYAN SANDS: I was thinking
about the success you've had.
And it's funny you mention Pen.
Your career sort of reminds
me of Pen a little bit.
Pen Ward is the creator
of "Adventure Time."
He started out doing a
lot of indie small comics.
It's a good thing, but because
of the popularity of the things
you've made, maybe it might be
hard to try out ideas, or try
experimenting.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: I
think he's in a corner
right now with that stuff.
His popularity is
really overwhelming.
RYAN SANDS: And the same could
be said for you too, I know.
Like any tweet gets--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: I feel
like I'm over the hump.
And I'm kind of moving on
with the rest of my life.
He's still in the
thick of it, for sure.
RYAN SANDS: Do you feel
like you have a space,
or what is your space for
sort of experimenting?
Like this is another big book.
And I think-- I know-- that
it's going to be very popular.
And so I was just
curious, do you
have a place to try out
ideas or just to tinker?
Where lots of Tumblr
kids and Twitter people
are following you?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Not really.
And I don't tend
towards doing that.
I tinkered plenty in this book.
I did lots of things
I wanted to try
and wanted to do differently.
And I keep telling
people lately I
wanna do some short
story, short comics.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah, I
saw you said that.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah,
which would be fun in theory.
It seems like a great idea.
And I want to do like-- I
really like some of the minis
and risograph stuff
that I've seen lately,
and stuff that you do.
And it'-- I think there's lots
of different spaces to do that.
And I like the idea of just
doing a 20 or 30-page story
and just dropping it online
for free, unannounced.
Like some day.
That would be fun.
RYAN SANDS: Do you
use-- do you mind
me asking-- I don't ask
about the process stuff,
but do you use a sketch book?
Or how do you keep
track of your thoughts?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
I'm terrible.
I buy sketchbooks.
RYAN SANDS: It
wasn't a judgement.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: No, I know.
I used to.
I used to use the
sketchbook all the time.
But lately I just write down
ideas in Notepad, or Evernote,
or one of those things.
And it's like a jumble.
And I'm terrible at
picking up a pen.
I never do it.
I don't draw when I'm
not working on a book.
Like the signings I'm
doing this week will
be the most drawing
I've done all year.
RYAN SANDS: Do you
have a wrist guard?
We have a lot of
ergonomics here at Google.
Like ergonomic keyboards.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: I just
kind of work on my posture.
RYAN SANDS: It's working.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
I try.
RYAN SANDS: I saw a
couple of friends of ours
who worked with you on
the book as assistants.
Justin Harben I know
lettered the book.
And then Jason Fisher did some
pencils and some background
drawings.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
Burgers.
RYAN SANDS: Drew burgers.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
and Nathan Fairbairn from
Vancouver did the colors.
He's also been doing the
colors in "Scott Pilgrim."
RYAN SANDS: And
like we said, comics
are great to read
and really fun.
But I know making
them can be intense.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Can be very solitary.
Yeah.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
So it must have
been-- what was it
like to have collaborators
or people to talk to?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: It was cool.
So I guess I've been working
with Nathan for about two
or three years now on the
"Scott Pilgrim" books, which
has been a more
and more fruitful
collaboration as it goes on.
We can kind of read each
other's mind a little bit.
He knows what I want, and
I'm happy with what he does.
Volume 5, we just finished.
I barely have any notes at all.
It was just like, this looks
great, this looks great.
Maybe change the color of
her boots, or whatever.
And with "Seconds," I had a
very specific vision in mind.
But I just send him a
vision board of stuff.
RYAN SANDS: Like a
Pinterest board or--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
No, it was an Evernote
file, actually.
We us Evernote.
I think Evernote is very clunky.
But I still use it
because it's useful.
I sent him pages from this
French comic called "Beauty"
by [INAUDIBLE] and
[INAUDIBLE], which
is so amazing, so beautiful.
And the colors are so perfect.
So I ripped it off, wholesale.
And also the movie
"The Secret of Nimh."
RYAN SANDS: Oh yeah.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: About
the mice, from the '80s.
RYAN SANDS: Yes.
I love that movie.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: I had
not seen it until last year,
they played it at the screening
at the New Beverly in LA.
So I saw that as
a double feature
with the Chipmunk Adventure.
RYAN SANDS: "Secret of
Nimh" is scary, isn't it?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: It's
very dark and weird.
But the color palette
again, was beautiful.
And it was actually very
similar to the color palette
in "Beauty," so I sent him
a whole bunch of stills
from that and pages
from "Beauty."
And then I had
already colored part
of the book in just a few tones.
And I knew I wanted
a lot of red,
so it was very
intuitive from there.
And he's very hands-on
and very dedicated.
He would go through
the entire book.
I mean, coloring
comics takes forever.
It's horrible.
RYAN SANDS: It's
like making sausage.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
It's horrible work.
I feel bad for him.
He's like a little
slave orphan boy.
But he would go
through the whole book
and change the color of
one thing, just on a whim
without even me saying anything.
He would be like, I just
don't like how this looks.
He would do like
150 pages of work
just for himself, for
his own peace of mind.
So again, that's how
dedicated he was to it.
And it was crazy.
RYAN SANDS: Did you do any
of that stuff in person?
Or was it all remote?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
I was gonna say next.
Jason, my drawing
assistant, ended up
staying with me for like the
last-- it was like five weeks,
but it was two and a half.
And then he went
home for a week.
And then two and a half more.
RYAN SANDS: A comic's camp.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: So yeah.
We totally camped out.
He stayed at my house
for a month and a half.
And it was great actually.
I'd never worked side by
side with anyone on the books
before.
I was worried it
would be awkward.
But we got along really well.
We spent most of the
time with headphones on,
just doing our own thing.
But then we would kind of
confer from time to time.
And it definitely led to better
ideas and a more structured
visual approach
throughout the whole book.
We were able to go over
everything in more detail.
It was just fun.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
Yeah, it must be nice
to have another person.
Because cartoonists
are a weird beast,
because you spend all this
time working on this thing.
And then you hope
someone will look at it.
And then you go to these cons
that are like summer camp.
And you're like, Hi.
Please like me.
So to actually get to have
the creative process together
must have been fun.
Did you-- I think I saw
you said in an interview
this week that the ending
changed a little bit.
During that time, you kind of
reworked some of the ending.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
I rewrote it.
I can't really remember what
the original ending was.
And you guys probably
haven't even read it.
I just I ended up just having--
after a 16-hour work day,
I was lying in bed.
I couldn't stop
thinking about the book.
That's that whole thing
where when you stop working,
you try to stop thinking about
it, then the idea comes to you.
I had this whole idea for
a new 16-page sequence
two weeks before the book
was supposed to be turned in.
And yeah, somehow we did it.
We did everything.
Even though we still
had probably 40 pages
to do in those two weeks.
We did the whole thing.
RYAN SANDS: Deadlines.
That's the only reason
any comic ever gets done.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Editorial and just the threat
of not having it out in time
for Comic Con or whatever.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
Wow.
That's cool.
I think we're going to
have some time for you guys
to ask questions in a minute.
And then I think we'll do
a book signing after that.
But I had a couple more things.
One thing I saw
you mentioned was
that you're interested in games.
And I thought a lot of your
storytelling and the characters
you created especially would
be such a great fit for games.
Is that something
you're doing now,
or you're interested in trying?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
I worked on the "Scott
Pilgrim" video game
with a really cool team
of guys from Montreal.
And they are still doing work.
And we're trying to
start a new game.
Just like from the ground up.
RYAN SANDS: Not
a "Seconds" game.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: No.
Although I think a "Seconds"
game would be really cool.
RYAN SANDS: It's like
"Cooking Mama" and then--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: But it
has a time reversal mechanic.
It's like Braid meets Tapper.
I was playing a lot of Tapper
at this arcade near my house.
RYAN SANDS: These are
like really good ideas
we're throwing away
into the public.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Well.
Whatever.
This is a confidentiality
agreement.
You guys all signed that.
Yeah.
So I'm just trying to start
a game with these dudes.
I won't say anything
about it, because it's
super early stages.
But yeah, trying
to create something
that satisfies me
as a storyteller,
but also I'm
working hand in hand
with this game developer, Dom2D,
who is like a really cool guy.
I think it'll be really fun.
And maybe it won't
be what I envision,
but I like that
process of-- basically
like a process of reduction.
Like a huge idea
that gets scaled down
to this manageable
framework to actually create
something that'll get done ever.
I still wanna do comics, too.
But--
RYAN SANDS: If you do a JRPG,
it could get really big.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: We
immediately nixed that idea.
But maybe next time.
But this time we're going to do
something with a smaller scope,
but that also is
satisfying for me.
My thing is I like characters.
I like character interactions.
I feel like there's not
enough of that in games.
There's too much
focus on yourself.
I think there needs to be more
interactions and friction.
I think that's
what appeals to me.
I'm trying to-- at every
step of the way-- games that
are sent to me, this whole
theoretical document.
And I'm like, where can we
fit more humanity into it.
Yeah.
It is a Google doc.
I use a lot of Google Drive.
Let's mention all
the Google products.
RYAN SANDS: We don't, no.
We don't do that.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: We did
use Google Drive for "Seconds"
though.
But I paid for it.
RYAN SANDS: Oh I see.
OK.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
No one else did.
I was the boss.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah,
I think there's
a lot of cartoonists
trying out games now.
I've seen a lot more people
going into that world,
because of the
storytelling potential.
That's an interesting spot.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
Art and graphics.
Wait-- graphics are art.
RYAN SANDS: Words.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Words and
pictures are in games, as well
as in comics, so it makes sense.
Yeah.
RYAN SANDS: That's cool.
So I think we'll
open up to questions.
If anyone in the audience
wants to ask Bryan a question.
I'll give you guys a minute to
get your courage and thoughts.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
You guys are too chill.
AUDIENCE: So I
was wondering, you
mentioned that during
the "Scott Pilgrim" movie
that you were involved
with the making.
And I was wondering
if there were
any of the scenes or
parts of the movie
that you were not so happy with
the way that they turned out.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Even four years later, I
would hate to say it.
Because so much work
went into all of it.
And I respect all the work.
And it's such a
complicated process
that it's hard to
pick anything out.
And there's parts
of the movie that
are so much better than
the corresponding part
of the comic, in my mind.
Like they were able to polish
it and make it funnier,
and make it more exciting,
and more visually
dynamic and stuff.
So that was really
depressing as the cartoonist.
I was like, I can never do this.
I can never make
things this exciting,
because I'm just working
with static images.
The other thing is, I got to
see a rough cut of the movie
before I finished the last book.
So I feel like I got to
address some of my concerns
with the ending of
the movie in the book.
Like I was able to
inject more affection
for some of the characters.
Because I think at the end
of the movie, if anything,
my complaint is that it becomes
action-oriented and loses
track of the heart.
So with the last book, I was
able to give the characters
more time and more
love, I guess.
RYAN SANDS: And the
book's the final word.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Well, for some people.
AUDIENCE: Now that
you've got "Seconds" out,
in terms of writing, what are
you kind of looking to do next?
Can you give us
any sneak previews?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Well like I said,
I think I'm going to
do some short stories,
because I just have various
ideas like kicking around,
that I wouldn't want to flush
out into a larger project.
But that would be fun.
And it would be fun
to do different art
styles and different genres,
and actually do a collection.
And I'm trying to
write a video game.
What else am I trying to do?
RYAN SANDS: Give us more.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
I want to do another series.
That's my next big goal.
Like I want to do
another-- my real followup
to "Scott Pilgrim"
kind of thing.
But it's probably
still a year or two
off before I'll start that.
It'll be great.
Yeah, I'm thinking
about serialization.
Because "Scott Pilgrim" was like
one book a year, or one book
every 15 months or whatever.
And I want to try to
and do more than that,
or more granular level
of serialization.
But I just don't know
what format will be best.
So I'm just kind of looking
at my options right now.
RYAN SANDS: I know
from other friends,
they said that serializing
a comic changes the way
they write it, in a major way.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: I
really want to try that,
because I've never done it.
AUDIENCE: As an artist, I was
really curious about the type
of media that you use
when you're drafting,
and when you reach
the final stages.
Like, are you on a tablet?
Is it all hand done?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
That's a good question.
For this book, I used the Wacom.
How do you say it?
Wacom.
Wockem.
I've seen them say it
in official videos,
and I still can't do it.
Anyway, I use a tablet screen.
Cintiq, for the penciling stage.
So I did all the roughs,
laid out the panels.
It's a lot easier to
do panels in Photoshop
because you can
do straight lines.
And you can move stuff around.
It's very fluid.
So that made sense to me
to compose things that way.
And then I've got a
large format printer,
and I printed everything
out in blue lines.
And I ink it traditionally
with a brush and ink.
So that's my backwards
approach to comics.
RYAN SANDS: Jillian Tamaki
does stuff that way, too.
She uses Manga Studio,
and then prints it out,
and then inks the printout.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
Jillian is like
me in that we just
like the tactile nature
of brush and paper.
So yeah, that's what started
to make the most sense to me.
I didn't get a
Cintiq until 2011.
I started doing posters
and comic covers and stuff.
And it's just so much
easier to compose graphics
and composition--
compose composition--
on a digital medium.
And then I just much
prefer to draw with ink.
AUDIENCE: So coming
from a Pen Ward's view,
we see his work generating
a lot of opportunities
for new, younger creators
who are then able to grow out
of it, especially from
animations standpoint.
Do you see talking about
these next stages in life,
the success of the
cartoonist being
where you grow opportunities for
others, and you share the work?
Or do you think there's still
a path for the individual
to sort of lock down in a
room, create great work,
and sort of churn it
out as an individual?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
That's a complex question.
I think I will
always do work that
is solitary to some degree.
And like what you say about
Penn Ward and "Adventure Time,"
to me it's complicated,
because "Adventure Time" is not
a comic.
It's a cartoon.
It's a totally
different medium, and we
have lots of cartoonists
friends who work on it.
And I don't think any of them--
some of them do animation--
but most of them just
do storyboards, which
is like a form of comics, but
it's all behind the scenes.
It's not really
for the public eye.
So I don't-- I'm glad all
my friends are getting work.
But at the same time, I
wish they could get money
doing their own work.
So really I feel like
my goal in life--
aside from my personal
creative goals--
is to somehow help
my friends all
become rich by doing
their own thing.
RYAN SANDS: Like Biggie Smalls.
You bring them up.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Yeah exactly.
You're a small publisher,
and you're stuff is so cool.
And there has to be more
ways for what you're doing.
That's my goal, is to take
any money and notoriety
that I have, and kind of
trying to turn it to those
ends, and try to
help people I know
who are deserving of success.
Because I don't need to go
any further success-wise.
I think I've gone as
far as I need to get.
If that answers any
of your questions.
I don't know.
RYAN SANDS: "Adventure
Time" is like Star Wars.
Now it's like a place where
other stories can happen.
And that can only happen
through collaboration.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: And so
many of my favorite cartoonists
and people work on that show.
And they're making
beautiful work.
I don't really watch
"Adventure Time."
I watch the occasional episode,
and they're always great.
But I just want to read more
comics from those people.
RYAN SANDS: Yeah.
Definitely.
We talk about that a lot.
They have health
insurance and jobs.
But then we don't see--
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: But I want
to see more of their work.
RYAN SANDS: More of
their comics, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
Do you ever have
commitment anxiety?
Like this comic,
it's going to take--
I have to put in so
many hours to this.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sort of
like-- am I sure
I want to spend time with these
characters that I've chosen?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Seven years.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that
something you work past?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
Well when I started
"Scott Pilgrim,"
I set out to do something that
would take years of my life.
It was a given that
it would take--
if I was going to
do six books, it
would take at least six years.
So that's kind of a big
thing to commit yourself
to when you're 24, 25-years-old.
And you don't really
know what that means,
and it's impossible to
know what that means.
But that is what
I set out to do.
I like comics that
are longer, that
have more of a
span to them, and I
like exploring
characters over time.
So I just thought that
that's what I had to do.
And I'm glad I did it.
And then this
"Seconds," I thought
it was going to take
maybe two years.
It ended up taking about four.
Which sucks.
And I mean, I had the
idea for "Seconds"
right after the first
"Scott Pilgrim" book.
So after like book three
or four, I was like,
can I just stop doing
"Scott Pilgrim" forever,
and just do "Seconds" instead?
Yeah.
There's always moments of doubt.
And then I just funneled
all those moments of doubt
into my book about doubt
that is called "Seconds."
And in doing "Seconds," it
was like-- so like halfway
through "Seconds," I did 150
pages of roughs on the Cintiq.
And then I hurt
myself, and I literally
couldn't hold a
pen for six months.
I thought I would
never finish the book.
And I can't believe I
did finish the book.
There's like parallel
realities, like this
is the best one for sure.
Or maybe there's one
where I didn't get hurt.
That would be better.
So this is pretty good.
I'm glad I finished the book.
Because yeah,
there's self-doubt.
There's physical obstacles.
And life gets in the way.
But I'm just driven to
actually tell the story.
RYAN SANDS: Gives you a lot
of time to simmer the idea.
Right?
Like suss out what's
actually good about it.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
I think the time off
in the very middle
of the book actually helped.
Which sucks to think about.
I wouldn't want to
go back four years
and tell myself, oh,
you're gonna spend
almost a year not
working on this book,
and just thinking about it,
and feeling bad about yourself.
But it's like it all
ends up in the book.
And I think it's a
stronger book for it.
AUDIENCE: I got a haircut.
But I'm not a fan or anything.
RYAN SANDS: You guys can't
see, but there's a cosplay.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Come here.
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah.
And this is Ramona here
in roller blades, too.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
That's just her outfit.
She's not dressed up.
RYAN SANDS: We have cos
players in the building.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Do you work here?
Where's security?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
My little story is that
I was Scott Pilgrim
for two Halloweens in a row.
And I was devastated how few
people in the techy community
recognized it.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Really?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY:
Do they watch movies?
They download them, but
then don't watch them.
They put them on a hard drive.
AUDIENCE: Did I even
have a question?
Oh, do you like web comics?
What's your thought?
Have you ever considered
a daily, weekly comic
or something?
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: No.
Hm.
I haven't been reading
a lot of them lately.
Some of my good friends do them.
Octopus Pie by Meredith Gran.
It's one of my favorites.
She's one of my favorite people.
RYAN SANDS: You could serialize
your new thing online and then
collect it in books.
This is what a lot of
people are doing now.
BRYAN LEE O'MALLEY: Yeah.
I mean, that's an option.
A lot of people
are doing-- aside
from "web" web comics--
a lot of people
are doing online PDF
sales and stuff like that,
which I think is cool.
But most of my friends aren't
doing "web comic" web comics
right now.
I don't know who's doing them.
I'm not really paying that
much attention to them.
RYAN SANDS: Can everybody help
me thank Bryan for coming.
Thanks again, Bryan.